en fait parce que c'était justement
proctor vraiment derrière j'ai peur de
me faire mal clémence brenier 22 euros
découvre les bases du badminton au
vélotour national de saint quentin en
yvelines
la débutante s'est inscrite avec une
amie ce samedi de descendre à
l'événement bad au féminin organisé pour
la première fois dans la structure ça
avait l'air d'être un bon moment qui est
une initiation au badminton c.st sport
qu'on a tous fait je pense au collège et
c'était un peu on n'a pas ça pas
forcément du haut niveau tout ça et
j'avais envie de découvrir un peu plus
ce sport
clémence fait partie des 23 joueurs qui
se sont inscrits pour ce rendez-vous
objectif annoncé de l'événement pousser
les femmes à s'inscrire le badminton
compte plus de 6000 y sont si dans les
yvelines mais reste encore
confidentielle au niveau féminin
le bad féminin représente un quart de ce
chiffre là donc à l'idée c'est de
vraiment à essayer de d'amener les
femmes à faire du badminton ski est un
sport accessible à tous pour rendre
l'initiation encore plus conviviale les
coaches avaient organisé un film in town
pendant une trentaine de minutes le but
après les déplacements au rythme de la
musique
si en badminton on sait pas se déplacer
on va difficilement pouvoir être à temps
sous les volants c'est un jeu où on
essaye de mettre en crise d'autant
toujours l'adversaire et du coup pour le
mettre en crise de temps on va essayer
de jouer là où il n'est pas et pour ça
il va falloir se déplacer le plus
rapidement possible et c'est toute une
sorte de jeu d'appui
voilà qu'il faut passer par un
apprentissage et du coup c'est un
apprentissage le fit nintendo qui permet
d'être beaucoup plus ludique
après le succès rencontré cette année
une deuxième édition devrait être
organisée l'année prochaine au mois de
décembre
toujours au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines